in this case study we're going to see
how we can create a photo illustration
of your work the idea here is to show
how a liquid battery works for a final
illustration so first create
photographic bits and pieces and put
them all together think of it just as if
you were drawing the pieces and putting
those sketches together after I met with
the researchers for a brainstorming
meeting I got all of this material from
them including a diagram that described
my idea to create a model of how a
liquid battery works this is the way I
imagined the shoot to go okay first I
would take an optical quality cuvette
and would then pour the mercury and the
water into the cuvette and somehow
suspending with a clamp a strip of metal
foam which is an important part of the
science and because I was imagining a
full container of this material after
making the image I would then crop out
the right side we don't need to see the
clamping device and then flip the left
side or a small portion of the left side
over to the right to then make the full
container and the final model now
remember this is not a documentary image
this is a photo illustration for
hopefully a cover submission that's the
idea okay so first I start looking at
the cuvette the vessel into which I was
going to be inserting and pouring all
the components I put it on a lightbox
and liked what I saw the picture was
going to be simple and licked fairly
well then I practiced inserting the
metal foam with a clamping apparatus to
see if it was doable and it was at least
with an empty container sort of dry run
so to speak so the next photograph I
took was with the Mercury and water in
the container which looked fine too
I then discarded that by the way into
special container the researchers
provided and sort of started all over
again
and tried for the next steps which was
going to be inserting the foam at a
certain level with the water I played a
little with lighting by shining a
tungsten lamp on to it it gave a warmer
feel which I liked then I plopped it
further into the water to see how that
was going to look and again I changed
the lighting by adding a little lamp
light onto this material so I was
getting there
eventually this is the image that I
wound up with well sort of wound up with
and I'll tell you frankly I was a bit
nervous dealing with the mercury and
pouring it out and dealing with that and
the water especially while having the
important cautionary instructions always
sitting in front of me so again making
the pieces photographically and then
putting them together was the way to go
remember this is an illustration using
photographs for the purpose of creating
a model of the technique of how a liquid
battery works and this is how I did it
I'm using Photoshop here but you can use
other software of course and take a look
at the real-life part of this where
we're using one images for the receiver
of the piece on the right side which is
what we had been talking about so I'm
first going to select the right side
copy and paste into the image on the
left side the container with all the
material move it around a little bit see
if it has the potential of being doable
it's not bad I think when it's flattened
it'll look better I think it can work so
I will in fact flatten the image and if
you remember we were going to crop out
the right side which is what we're going
to do here crop make the image as full
as we can with
out the right-side cropping it out okay
that looks pretty okay and now as we had
previously talked about in the animation
we're going to flip one side to another
but first in order to do that I'm going
to expand the canvas to make room for
the new piece that we're going to start
working with so I am in fact taking a
piece at the left side which is what we
talked about
I'm copy and pasting there it is again
and we're going to flip it to make up
for the empty side we'll just flip it
horizontally move it around a bit and
with a little fudging we get a pretty
nice start for an image that we're
getting to I decided to play more about
raising it one more level and so I went
back to what we have seen before and in
another image where I basically take
this pretty good image select the
background invert the selection so that
we have in fact selected the liquid
battery copy and paste and you see here
we have another layer of just the liquid
battery and went to layer style and went
back to our old drop shadow friend and I
played with making a drop shadow which I
did like I tend to think that it just
pushes it away and I think it worked
quite well eventually what I did wind up
doing is playing a little bit with
putting a different background for
example making a gradient that wasn't
going to work I didn't even know what I
had in mind but I really wanted
something a little more dramatic so
going back to the picture without the
color in the background on keeping the
drop shadow I went to adjustments
decided to invert the whole picture and
yes that's quite a unusual image and but
decided to do it and play a little bit
with the hue to get that blue back to
the orange that I sort of liked wasn't
quite enough I increase the saturation a
little bit and there it is this was the
final image that I showed to the
researcher and frankly I think we got
ourselves a winner unfortunately not the
cover of the journal which I really we
were hoping that would happen but it did
get the home page of the journal and a
couple of other home pages of various
journals and it got a lot of attention
first of all of course the science was
important but we pretty much agree that
making an image to draw attention to the
science really is what this image making
is about I hope you enjoy this and see
the thinking that is extensive when you
get into something that's complicated